you know people
love it uh when i ask about books i
don't know
if uh books whether fiction non-fiction
technical or completely non-technical
had an
impact in your life throughout if
there's anything you would recommend
or even just mention as something that
gave you an insight
or moved you in some way so
okay so i don't know if i recommend
because in some sense
you almost had to be italian or to be
such a scholar but being italian
one thing that really
impressed me tremendously is the divine
comedy
it is a medieval poem a very long poem
divided in three parts hell purgatory in
paradise okay
and the vet is the non-trivial story
of a middleman man
gets into a crisis personal crisis and
then
out of this crisis he purifies
mesa catastrophe purifies himself more
and more and more until
he's become capable of actually meeting
god
okay and this event is actually a
complex story
so you have to get some very
sophisticated
language maybe latino at that point that
we were talking about
1200s italy right um
in in florence and this guy instead he
chose
his own dialect not spoken outside his
own
immediate circle right um a florentine
dollar and actually
he dante really made italian italian he
was
and it's honestly how can you express
such a sophisticated things and so this
and then the point is that these words
that uh nobody actually knew because
they were essentially dialect
and plus a bunch of very intricate
rhymes in whichever to rhyme with things
and turns
out that by getting meaning from the
things with the rhyme you essentially
guess what the world means
and you invent italian and you
communicate
by almost osmosis what you want is a
miracle of communication
in a dialect a very poor language very
unsophisticated to express a very
sophisticated
situation i love it
people who love it and italians are not
italian
but but what i got of it is that you
know very often
limitations are our strength because if
you limit yourself at a very poor
language
somehow you get out of it and you
achieve even better form of
communication if you're using a
hyper sophisticated and literary
language with lots of resonance from the
prior books so that you can actually
instantaneously quote he couldn't quote
anything because nothing was written in
italian before him
so i really felt that limitations are
our strength
and i think that rather than complaining
about eliminations
we should embrace them because
if we impress our limitation limited as
we are we find
very creative solutions that people with
less limitation we have we would not
even think about it
oh the limitation is a kind of
superpower if you choose to see it that
way
you